eeuu y la unión europea han sellado una
alianza para garantizar el suministro de
gas en europa en plena crisis con rusia
washington y bruselas quieren asegurarse
que el gas seguirá fluyendo al
continente sobre todo en pleno invierno
y sin rusia decide invadir ucrania y los
países europeos aplican sanciones a
asegurarse que el kremlin aunque cierre
el grifo del gas el continente pueda
estar asegurado con esta colaboración
eeuu así también se asegura que los
países europeos decidan aplicar duras
sanciones a moscú en caso de que sea
necesario intentar de que no se pueda
suministrar suficiente en gas hay que
tener en cuenta que europa depende mucho
del gas de rusia y aunque han aumentado
las importaciones de gas proveniente de
otros países ahora se quiere aumentar
sobre todo la importación de gas licuado
proveniente de eeuu con un
almacenamiento que podría llegar al 80
por ciento en el continente además
también los países europeos mantienen
contactos con otros países como por
ejemplo con qatar
del consejo europeo transmisión y la
presenta de la comisión europea ínsula
von der leyen ha mentido contactos en
las últimas horas con las autoridades
qataríes también para importar gas
además los países europeos aseguran que
podrán mantener el suministro también a
ucrania en caso de invasión por parte de
rusia así las cosas los países europeos
están ahora a la espera de que moscú
responda a las cartas de la otan y de
estados unidos- en que abordaron sus
líneas rojas y también los márgenes de
negociación